ignore those school board moms at your
peril like it or lump it democrats in
the media still not getting the message
over why they got their butts kicked in
virginia republican senator rick scott
calling out cnn over why parents
revolted in the old dominion
it's not in the curriculum
um in virginia but just just
like me here let me just read you a few
things just in 2015 while terry
mcauliffe was governor the virginia
department of education promoted
incorporating a critical race theory
lens and education you can still find it
on the department of education's website
still there
in february 2019 a superintendent member
for the virginia department of education
promoting crystal race theory and the
idea of white fragility i hope democrats
continue to say it's not happening
because parents are dumb
they can see it they look so unhappy on
seeing that yeah because they are
and yet dnc chair jamie harrison still
doubling down on the notion that racism
was behind the republican victories they
understand that the only path to power
for them is to to make the american
people scared to to come up with all of
the dog whistles and the boogeyman and
all of that democrats have to call out
the lies and we have to be bold and
calling them out
and we got to make sure that we paint
the contrast let people know what we
have done for them
well i think he's right about that
democrats if they have achievements
should be promoting their achievements
stegan but as a resident of as a as
someone who hails from the old dominion
don't you think race
is relevant
for children growing up in virginia
because virginia was like the heart and
soul of the slave economy
history is taught history should be
taught that's not what critical race
theory is about and it's not the problem
that parents and virginians had when
they went to the polls and elected a
republican governor and a republican
lieutenant governor the first black
woman ever elected to statewide office
and a republican attorney general
there i mean i could sit here for days
and go over what is being taught in the
virginia schools that they take issue
with it's a it's derived from say the
ideas in albemarle county from uh ibram
kindy author of how to be an anti-racist
uh
children being taught words like
cisgender white privilege non-christian
folks with an ex
uh and view like issues of
gender race sexuality things that
parents feel like should be up to them i
digress but i love watching brianna
keeler or whatever her name is belching
up what her liberal overlords have told
her to regurgitate it's got to burn
i love how they
they will take parents are delusional
wackos and then trump and russia
collusion and they say something real is
made up and then say something made up
is real that's the world in which we
they live it is uh
their evangelist of left-wing more
honesty but you can't ignore it race
matters yeah race does matters and
that's what the parents were saying we
don't like being taught reverse racism
we don't want our students our children
being called born racists in elementary
school i want to talk about brianna go
ahead i don't like to do this because i
don't like to ever mention these people
by name i feel like i want to be loved
and i don't ever want to see these
people at bars and have their wives or
their husbands throw haymakers at me
yeah i don't like to punch down like gut
fell don't want to you know elevate the
competition but i can only punch up at
my height
i think we need to address brianna
maybe she's nice maybe we'd get along if
we met each other but she is on a
network that says
facts first and she at this point
doesn't know
that crt is embedded in the curriculum
of the virginia school system
at this point she doesn't know this this
story's been percolating since april and
she doesn't know that i mean does she
now also think the dossier was real does
she think the younkin supporters were
the ones with the tiki torches does she
think geraldo yes that those two
brothers actually did knock around jesse
smallett that night in chicago because
i don't know if her producers are not
giving her the right information if i
were brianna i would blame the producers
too
that's what i do but
this is why our show's so much better
than that show so many reasons here's
one we get these research packets in the
morning and they have facts in the
packets brianna and they also have
articles from the left and the right so
you know what the left is saying about
an issue you know what the right saying
about an issue you know what the media
is saying about an issue and then we as
hosts do our own research and we look
for the truth and then we formulate our
opinions based on that truth
so
there's truth out there it's on the
internet she could look that up anywhere
she wants
and if i ever make a mistake on the air
i will go about and correct it and
that's a few times i've been challenged
and then in the commercial break i say
maybe i'm wrong here nope not wrong and
then the other person has to correct the
record for instance the other day i said
erroneously that the staff
was not trendy and i immediately
corrected the record and i think brianna
should do the same thing the staff was
not trending yeah wendy oh train
i gave them my shirt oh they're the
secretary doesn't it remind you dana
isn't it parallel to the old uh teaching
sex ed to third graders and fourth
graders i mean parents are edgy
generally speaking well you're young i
don't remember that but uh remember they
don't want like graphics check it out in
a commercial break this is the boys i
think a lot of this also has to do with
many people who are commenting about
this and saying it has nothing to do
with these schools um they don't have
school-age children
and if you look at the exit polls in
virginia
parents of school-age children k-12 went
for yunkan by a huge margin
and so
they have taken on parents and they've
made them mad and but the parents were
not just mad about the crt thing they're
mad that the schools were closed for so
long that there was a major loss of
learning that they don't even have the
opportunity to have gifted and talented
programs and advanced math when in it
when when junkin says i will make sure
that every high school has advanced math
and he gets applause that's when you
know parents are really paying attention
and they're making a mistake not doing
the same do you really believe in your
heart of hearts greg
that it isn't a signal
dana talks of virtue signaling isn't
there
race signaling also when you look at
some of the rural counties in virginia
that went for yunkan by 80 percent 80 to
20. isn't there something about isn't
race relevant to that
some white
not in this era maybe if that question
was 50 years ago
in my family a bunch of bigots so let's
just be clear yeah but you know but
there is a there is a lot of this
race-baiting but it's all in reverse for
example
calling this history when in the the
title of it it says theory oh it's
critical race theory it is not history
that's why it's not that sex education
is not a parallel uh analogy because
that's education this is merely theory
the woke demands that you'd give them
proof and you saw what happened with
brianna she's not woke she says dim
and she's so she you guys have been no
no she had no no you have to point this
out she asked for proof and when he gave
her proof she didn't want to hear it
because she knew she was in the wrong so
she just put that scowl on people like
chris ruffo and this show remember this
show when we first started doing this
topic we had the examples in the in our
copy that said this is where crt is
taught and this is what crt is the irony
and the best part about this is when you
hear proponents of crt try to define it
and you hear critics try to define it
the definition is entirely the same
that's what kills me they're not
disagreeing identify children by their
race within a country riven with
systemic racism with a conclusion that
white is the oppressor right and black
is the victim if you say that the
proponents will go that's pretty good
you got it and the critics will go
you're absolutely right that's exactly
what they're saying so they're they're
in agreement here that's the funniest
part about this and it is dead because
the parents finally woke up to this and
found out that this was dangerous
children are not equipped at that age to
discuss this topic especially when
adults can't talk about it either yeah i
think the tragedy is
racist black people are democrats white
people are republicans in the working
class and the country is permanently
divided by race i think it's tragic who
fought that in slavery
democrats or was the republicans i can't
remember it was
north and the people where i grew up
voted on pocketbook issues they voted on
job creation they voted on charter
schools and black and black and white
was irrelevant come on
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else